vivek ramaswamy is the author of woke
inc and a very smart man he joins us
tonight so veg thanks so much for coming
on um one of now your parents came to
this country from another country one of
the things that immigrant families have
that native born americans don't is an
appreciation of the fragility of
economies they don't imagine that
everyone's going to be rich for all time
just because they were born in a rich
country
and watching these people talk
you really feel like that's what they
believe this can kind of go on forever
we keep printing the money everyone's
got more than enough more drag time
story hours
exactly tucker first of all talking
about being woke it is the ultimate
privilege the reason you don't see
wokeness infecting poor countries is
that they have bigger things to worry
about like people putting food on the
dinner table this is the ultimate
privilege but now as the united states
goes from being well off to being less
well-off in all the ways you laid out
inflation supply chain shortages
watching foreign policy disasters abroad
you now see the people who are in power
the biden administration using and
projecting these progressive values as a
smoke screen to deflect accountability
for their actual policy failures right
so you mark my words tucker the more
inflation we see the more supply and
change shortages we see the more foreign
policy disasters we see the more you're
going to see the biden administration
talking about racism or misogyny that's
right bigotry or whatever as a way of
changing the subject that's exactly
right actually
you saw it in afghanistan for example
you have the taliban coming to power you
have actual terrorists coming to power
in a place that we left just a couple of
months ago and yet the thing that we're
actually talking about with merrick
garland is domestic terrorism in the
form of parents who are actually putting
up protests to the way their kids are
being taught in school classic example
of changing the subject and mark my
words you're going to see more of it as
the policy failures continue to rack up
you blame the trotsky records for the
failure of the potato harvest and our
trust gateway is your white supremacist
no no one's ever seen one uh but they're
everywhere i do think that's a pretty
hard case to make though in the face of
increasing poverty can you actually
convince people that they're getting
poorer because q anon is bad
so you know you had this battle on the
left tucker not a lot of people on the
right appreciate this distinction you've
got the occupy wall street left that's
mostly been left in the in the sand for
10 years yes and then you have the new
woke left that's actually held the reins
over power now as you begin to see
economic recession and economic
consequences in this country as you
begin to see inflation as you begin to
see gas prices go up i think you're
actually going to see the rise of the
occupy wall street left come back and
say we on the left need to be going back
to arguing about economic inequality as
opposed to talking about racism and
misogyny and bigotry and you know what i
think that's going to be a good thing
for the left i think it's going to be a
good thing for this country because
that's ultimately what the left and
right ought to be arguing about they can
have different views on redistribution
or taxation policy or what the right
economic policies are but that is what
we need to be talking about we need to
be talking about our reliance on china
which isn't a left-wing issue or
right-wing issue that's right both
parties frankly are guilty for it for
the last 30 years so i think this could
actually in the long run be good for the
country getting us back on topic talking
about the things we need to be talking
about as opposed to the woke smoke that
the biden administration and their
corporate cronies blow every day to
change the subject i couldn't agree more
you know this is a serious country it's
a great country it deserves a serious
conversation we haven't had one for
years and i i anyway i appreciate you
saying that vic thank you so much hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else